hey guys welcome back to new rock stars
Angela Molina and this is my good friend
mr. Sam basher
oh it's great to be here especially
because what you're seeing right here
it's two very happy boy
two happy boys because even though we
are insanely swamped with trailers from
comic-con that works so so good we just
got done with our Millions watch of the
kick-ass new trailer for the Justice
League movie and this trailer takes so
many boxes for us that I'm going to be
the first one to admit I don't think the
DCU had been hitting constant home run
but this movie's following up the
amazing Wonder Woman it feels like they
might be back on track with a really
bright future by the way a four-minute
trailer that somehow doesn't give away
the entire plot thank you thank you so
much but let's get into this and point
out some of the things you guys might
yes by-the-by potential spoiler warning
for the Justice League but you know that
already
now to the cover of the Aerosmith cover
of The Beatles version have come
together and roll the clip
what did you do this weekend me sir
nothing very interesting so we've got
this thing that kind of looks like a
robbery of some sorts though it actually
seems to go in a different direction
that we will realize later in the
trailer and of course we're starting off
the Justice League trailer with Diana
Princess of the mascara because yeah
she's a beacon of hope loved by
everybody but really she's the best
received thing the DC EU has going for
it and it's as smart of them to milk
that goodwill we're all feeling toward
her and I think that they're actually
referencing in the cinematography of all
this the most beloved DC movie of all
time I'll be it from a slightly
different universe the aesthetics the
angles I think this is all purposely
meant to feel a bit like the opening
scene to the Dark Knight you just gotta
imagine these guys wearing clown masks
which themselves by the way we're
references to this as a Romero's Maps
back in 1966 anyways if you listen
carefully based on the actions of our
boys we can infer that this takes place
somewhere in the UK probably London
pretty cool but we'll get into more of
that later including why there is so
much focus on this briefcase moving
along we have Diana burst to the doors
which is worth checking out for anybody
frame by the way it is amazing and she's
dodging bullets and slow-mo like she do
and then we get a shot of her later at
work probably still at the Louvre and
maybe commuting to London for her nice
gig but know what her job is in the DCE
she's a restorer of ancient artefact I
don't mean is that relevant because
Diana herself is an ancient artifact but
she actually comes from a time when
these artifacts weren't ancient they
mean a lot to her but not just because
they were from her time but also because
she's not been able to return to her
home for many decades now so these are
one of her only ways to connect back to
her people
oh now as we've done the world remains
in mourning after the death of the
Superman
is a way on the wrath of the window
specter doors there are ten asylum and
where's the garbage bag the mapper
Delaney has been a no-show
they said the Age of Heroes who never
come again
Pascal alright just some quick things to
note in this section as the voiceover
mentions the world is in mourning after
Superman's death and if you look closely
at the memorial on the bridge the color
scheme seems like an appropriately
somber choice but it's actually a nod to
Superman post resurrection in the comic
that's his new costume color scheme once
he returned moving forward past the
rubble still left over from the scene in
Batman V Superman where doomsday swing
Superman through a statue of himself we
get a close look at a big old Daily
Planet newspaper headline which by the
way I mean I think the headline is a
little bit alarmist but that's just me
world's loss all oh I think you just
sell more if you spun it more prior to
put some other specifics in there and
all about anything now if you know us
well you know we tried to figure out the
work on the rest of the newspaper and we
did well only kind of here's what we got
when we straighten it out and played
with it a little bit the top seems to
say metropolis continues the fight
against the tmd some acronym corporate
takeover and then at the bottom this is
a lot harder to decipher but the first
word could be a waiting but more likely
avoiding considering the rest of it
looks like it could say something about
in manage and threat maybe is that
really says an engine that could be
really interesting because it would
imply there's some sort of additional
threat to humanity other than you know
the world being destroyed by party tail
oh also this word here is English 4s
with Sam stands for on my world in me
joke assignment yes I know that it's a
symbol for the house of L but just
whatever anyway then regarding Gordon
lighting the bat-signal we see much
later that this location has the same
grim reaper statues adorning the roof
and we're crazy about that is that in
the DC Universe
the bat-signal is always a top of the
Gotham City Police Department in fact
you can see the GCPD shields in the shot
where Batman atop it how grim is the
situation in Gotham when instead of
having normal gargoyles on a building
the police department has decided to use
death in their design schemes not good
not good since it is almost always
gargoyles on the roof you
wonder some designer just thought it'd
be cool to show Batman standing the top
death like he may be immortal land but
somehow he's out of deaths reach right
and real quick before we move on did you
hear those news reporters voiceovers in
this footage maintain mourning after the
death of Superman there are two things
worth noting here first off apparently
there's a crime wave going on around the
world obviously this could be because
Superman isn't around to stop it anymore
but it could also be a duty to the
incoming invasion of apocalypse which is
the whole world of this movies villain
Steppenwolf and also he's more famous
nephew Darkseid okay so that may sounds
pretty out-there but the reason that
could be a tease to those characters
specifically is that in the comics when
Darkseid Steppenwolf and others new Gods
invade earth they usually are preceded
by an increase in nefarious or evil
activity in fact we saw that in the
final season of Smallville with the
apocalypse invading and it causing
people with evil tendencies to act out
and in the next news reporter is this
one with a French accent well listen
closely it sounds like our eccentric
villain from BBS Lex Luthor is being
moved to freakin Arkham Asylum now this
was a throwback to deleted scene from
Batman V Superman where Batman says Lex
is going to be transferred to Arkham and
Batman notes that he has some friends
there obviously it's exciting for
Batman's rogues gallery to be
potentially introduced through Arkham
Asylum may be equal see like a cryo cell
for mr. freeze or maybe like a
greenhouse thing for poison ivy but it's
also good to remember that Lex Luthor
also from a deleted scene actually has a
lot of insight on Steppenwolf and these
three mother boxes that likely play a
pivotal role in the movie so prediction
one I think we could be in for luthor
going loki and having to team up with
the good guys or at least be valuable to
them in some way
and since he's crazy now I wouldn't be
surprised it's like that doctor in
Independence Day too when he gets
reactivated with the aliens return to
Earth I call Madeline
oh and then definitely getting to knock
it off back hand for Batman yes I love
that I wanted that
[Music]
we don't have any one time something is
coming
so we got this epic shot of the mascara
and as we know from the Wonder Woman
movie Zeus himself hid this land away
from the world and yet a few moments
later it looks like Steppenwolf lands
directly there that shows you the power
of this thing a mother box even Zeus
magic can't trick them this is the first
one one get a good look at now mother
box is our device is used by our
invaders from apocalypse and they're
what Lex saw in his lesson on the
Kryptonian ship from what we can tell
there are three of these on earth one
here with the Amazons our guess is that
another one is with the Atlanteans and
the final that one's probably with the
normal human specifically Silas stone
cyborg that and that's the box that
essentially made cyborg or at least his
armor okay so boom our guess is that
Steppenwolf is on a mission to collect
these mother boxes once again in order
to bring the full-on invasion of
Darkseid and his minions to earth this
could be tied to what's going on later
in the trailer for stability to use the
like power gel retinas from inside
attacks which you can see here to kind
of terraform the earth and make it more
like apocalypse which is another thing
that often happens in depictions of this
invasion story oh by the way rewinding
for just a second that tunnel thing that
seven wolf drops out of that's our first
sighting of a live-action boon tube so
pretty cool this is a form of instant
transportation via portals or apocalypse
and New Genesis New Genesis is like the
sister planet to apocalypse if
apocalypse is held in New Genesis is
heaven sort of kind of you usually use
these tubes to travel anyplace you like
sometimes even other dimensions freaky
cool and fun facts and cyborgs Tech is
made from this same kind of technology
prediction to the team is going to have
to use him to either interface with the
mother box or a boom tube in damn
cyborgs just became an essential part of
this plot he gets to be in the movie hey
also before we move on we got to mention
how cool it is will bring Steppenwolf to
demo Sarah Deborah wolf and dart Center
literally referred to as New Gods event
the replacements for the Olympian God
so this conflict is much more direct
with the Amazon cousin Vaughn
don't protect teacher
[Music]
no monkeys
who could tell me
[Music]
moving on we get our first shot of
Arthur curry aka Aquaman swimming but if
you go back to the very beginning of the
shot you might notice he's warming up to
a statute based on the built up thrown
around of our guess is that this is an
ancient Atlantean King and considering
Christopher him Jew tormund Giantsbane
himself was cast as an ancient Atlantean
King we're starting two things that
we're going to get a flashback to
ancient Atlantis at some point possibly
when they receive and hide their mother
box in the past moving on we see Wonder
Woman in according to that sign Gotham
and then the powers going out so it
could be part of the attack but it also
could be related to the huge power spike
that could happen when cyborg is first
made now I know that happened over in
Metropolis most likely but do remember
that in the DCU these are sister cities
now the biggest thing to point out about
this section isn't on screen here 7 1 4
talking about how it's the perfect time
for apocalypse district okay check did
you know lanterns the Kryptonian is
really long like all the others are you
kidding me lanterns all of our hearts
flutter just a little bit at the mention
of lanterns meaning that the Green
Lantern Corps is out there officially in
the cosmos protecting civilization now
it kind of sounds like a lantern could
have already been protecting earth and
now they're gone
so how could that be well in Green
Lantern's Laura Ventura crash lands on
earth after being attacked in his ring
searches out Hal Jordan making how first
human Green Lantern snake moment from
there we get Jon Stewart Guy Gardner
Kyle Rayner Simon Baz and Jessica Cruz
being the main human lanterns so in this
movie maybe we're just before the human
lanterns coming into being and as for
Abin Sur maybe stefan wolf killed him
either way the little tease makes us
think that the Green Lantern could be
appearing the BPU before their full-on
Green Lantern Corps buddy cop movie but
we'll get back to how that could happen
later now real quick we've got
acknowledge that the Kryptonian costume
has to be Superman but can I just say
that I get why some people are confused
by how incredibly skinny this mannequin
thing's legs are these are such pretty
low like that and maybe people think
this could be Supergirl costume and also
even quicker I got to say how cool it is
to see the flash bending the shape of
the window before keep
breaks it there's a lot of concern that
the flash TV showed already used up all
the interesting ways to show the flashes
to super speeds but the way to keep it
fresh and eat is moment like this
trying cool new tricks now moving on
please
like all the others when this is the
days or months biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins okay a quick
section here just to point out two quick
things first you got a love alfred
reference to the penguin so now that's
another character that officially exist
in the DC EU but the exploding windup
penguins seem like a nod to the
multiverse theory where that's how it
played out in this universe but in a
different universe specifically the one
of Batman Returns the Penguins were wind
up but they did have rockets on them
also just in case we are going to get
the penguin on screen at some point in
the DCU let's do some fan casting who
should fly him if it happened trick
question the answer is always in DeVito
and then the other thing to point out
here Steppenwolf swinging is asked into
the ground and causing that red glowing
rupture sure if you're eagle-eyed you
can see his ships are behind him but if
you're an eagle with binoculars on you
might notice there are people at the far
edges of the rupture in fact if you look
extra close they appear to be warriors
but their attire makes them seem like
they're from a different time and while
this scene looks an awful lot like when
the Amazons are fighting symbols later
and this maybe could be the same moment
these people definitely do not look like
ladies so we've got a theory about who
they could be but also we've got some
evidence for it but first really really
quick we have to do a super fast
shout-out to our sponsor
speaking of warrior attire thank you to
our sponsor me undies for making this
trailer breakdown possible me and these
makes really high-end men's and women's
underwear but it's also cheap enough
that you can buy more instead of ever
having to do laundry in fact if you
subscribe they'll send you underwear
monthly but they'll take up to 33
percent off the price go to me and these
don't flush new rock stars and boom 20%
off your first order they've got bold
and adventurous looks but you could also
get the classic ones too in case you
know you've got a serious business
meeting that day and you've got your
pants also totally genuine here winnards
we need all the romantic help we can get
fresh new underwear will always be
better than those raggedy all growing
rappers we normally use oh and the legs
don't write up they won't turn into
thongs throughout the day they grip and
expand their thanks immunity's for
supporting these boys and these boys
back to it so who are these warriors
it's definitely survival well first you
gotta remember the footage from last
year's comic-con so that would mean that
if this is a flashback in this trailer
then it looks like these Viking types
actually succeed again Steppenwolf but
how could normal humans beat Steppenwolf
well ok this theory is where it gets
pretty out
considering this is the ancient past and
we know they've been casting roles like
this what if these here are the ancient
Atlantean mentioned earlier maybe even
before Atlantis sank right there
definitely was a time where they were
above ground and in the comics they are
very associated with Amazon another
ancient force of amazing warriors the
idea that those two forces come together
in the ancient past repel an apocalypse
an invasion would make a lot of sense
and could be the plot of an entire
history lesson flashback all right let's
keep going
this is crazy I think we're all gonna
die
each of us in some way is held back
run engage alone little live together
it's really cool you might ready to do
battle pushing some people so we see
Steppenwolf gathering its forces in what
most likely it's a ship or possibly his
fortress that he's go bonkers or even
his fortress back in Apocalypse which
ship or fortress are our guesses because
look at the edge this thing has Windows
fancy that it's surrounded by parademons
and looks to be walking toward the
glowing floating light which seems to be
either one of the three mother boxes or
one back on apocalypse based on the
design it seems like there's a lot of
focus on the boxes as a source of energy
which could be used as power source at
the old Steppenwolf doomsday machine
don't worry though
not actually doomsday ease very good if
it is a doomsday machine it could be
what's causing the sky to turn red as we
see here but also in a few other moments
too and by the way the sky turning red
isn't just the filmmakers deciding that
Gary blue clouds have had their time red
skies are reference to the comics where
red skies always mean issues with the
multiverse the most famous instance is
the crisis on Infinite Earths
story and then every follow up crisis
event actually but there's such a big
deal that the term red skies crossover
actually refers to how when things like
this happen there are a bunch of other
characters in that universe that aren't
connected to the main story and have no
idea what's going on so they just look
up and they're like great the sky is red
again something's probably going on that
I'm not part of moving up at bat manages
cool new goggles which I love and what
appear see a shot down flying foxes new
airship and the Batmobile flying out er
there we get a discussion team between
the league and boom right there on the
table they see containers well fancy
container probably holding a freaking
mother box okay these things are so
powerful and this one is just chilling
here on the table in what looks like
cyborgs lunch box now this has me
thinking that not only is the league
hiding this mother box from Steppenwolf
but at some point you might have to turn
that technology back on him somehow with
that back to my prediction number two
from earlier we didn't get a glimpse of
Dinah flipping in a place that we see a
lot in the rest of this trailer this -
like place and I'm guessing where the
climax of the movie happened in fact
that moment where they're all standing
together looks to be the same moment as
the big reveal of the team back in the
first footage we ever saw of this movie
moving forward there's a moment
where the team appears in this white
sterile environment and because cyborg
is taking the lead here seemingly
looking at something familiar I'm going
to guess that this is STAR Labs where
cyborg was created so in that case the
thing he's looking at could be the
mother box that made them and ends up in
his lunch box later or because I
technically him and in previous trailer
result one of those parademons attack
cyborgs that I think you could possibly
be looking at the very same parody mat
or Lisa's body that would make sense if
that emotion on his face right now is
discussed because in the comics cyborg
doesn't really love his new look and in
this iteration since his tech is the
same one that makes parademons it means
he looks a lot like them notice their
body similarities from later in the
trailer so it would make a lot of sense
if that's disgusting
and then we get my favorite lie in this
trailer I love because it's a reminder
that the flash is going to be as funny
as he usually is and also that he's not
going to be some expert he's a rookie
and he's got a lot to learn and he might
mess up a lot thank goodness honestly
the DCU takes the same approach that
Marvel did with spider-man flash both
here and in this upcoming solo movie
could be a lot of fun and yet feel very
different from the rest of the BPU all
right let's talk more
relax Alfred I'll take it from here
uh do I know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
in order to save people
completed best parts of themselves
alright the trailer is really picking up
the pace so we will to first thing to
point out is when cyborg appears in this
Batman tactical vehicle if you rewind
slowly you're going to notice he didn't
climb in he dropped like hundreds of
feet into it in fact look even more
closely he almost killed Batman doing it
vehicle by the way is the night crawler
right name it's around 30 feet tall it's
like a tank that's also spire like it
can actually use its legs to stab into
materials and break through incline so
Steppenwolf attacks in this tunnel which
could be the tunnel that connects
metropolis and Gotham maybe but we want
to talk more about this theme that looks
to be in Atlantis where Steppenwolf
throws his act at Aquaman now this could
be seven wolf stealing the Atlantean
mother box under water but also look out
Aquaman's pants he got those at H&M I
owned them myself
but actually I think that means that
Aquaman wasn't hanging out in Atlantis
but maybe has to rush down from the
surface world throwing his Hollister
shirt into the wind and diving down
quick as possible
to try to protect Atlantis and its box
and then this next shot is why we said
that we don't know if that courtroom
scene in the opening is much of a heist
because this looks to be the same place
the building that has the same design
the cop cars are British police and the
SFO refers to the specialist firearms
officers which are also affectionate
British police and so it looks like the
briefcase from earlier yeah they could
have actually been a bomb if that's the
case what does ex-fighter have against
courtrooms whythey always got to be
blowing them up teachers want to be a
Justice League too and finally I want to
point out Diana care this shot and move
is so similar to the one used in Batman
V Superman and I think the interesting
that we now know this wind up arm move
is how she generates the force to use
her God level cuff boom attack which is
definitely not an official name but
let's move on
[Music]
we'll have to recognize
she separated so we get some awesome
shots and I got a wonder if that wall of
water is in the same place diana was
pushing back Steppenwolf moments earlier
and if so I hope the rest of the team
isn't in there that doesn't look like
some ordinary smokestack thing by the
way based on the height of the buildings
around it they appear to be about five
storeys tall and that would place this
thing around four hundred and fifty feet
tall so maybe like 150 feet taller than
big ben and then finally this is a
really curious shot look closely at
their faces flash and cyborg both look
astounded diana looks mildly happy the
cops in the background are like what the
hell we got to call this in but this
location I'm pretty sure this is the
Superman statue memorial so if they're
amazed and happy about something
could this be Superman's return we're
seeing right here in this moment maybe
or we could just be that someone just
fix the statue real nice and they're
just not happy about it that's what's
exciting tell us what you think in the
comments but let's move on
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough
you really think this oh wow they just
they really just vanish oh that's rude
[Music]
we get a new glimpse of the Amazons
fighting a horde of parademons for home
and this not only looks amazing it also
looks like it could be matched to the
time with the Viking type guys from
earlier also skipping forward a bit we
see the Flying Fox firing at some sort
of shield or dome I don't ride so hard
to figure out what this is but can let
me know if you guys have any guests also
some folks really wanted us to talk
about the green light under the flying
fox because it could be Green Lantern
but I gotta say I'm pretty sure it's
just a green light and the next shot
there's another one too don't worry
we're bummed too and then Aquaman
freakin surfs on a para demon into a
building and then fix the landing with a
lash she's here with gorgeous I mean if
you're not in love with Jason Momoa as
Arthur curry now we're sorry he's a fat
if should we show you the move again
where he starts on parademon I mean it's
all of this cool as the intro to Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers when the white
Power Ranger wrote a snowboard out of a
plane that means then we get the scene
that we saw a snippet of at the
beginning with those crazy Grim Reaper
statues but I want to focus on what
Batman says when Gordon asked how many
of you are there now remember that
Batman knows about Amanda Waller's Task
Force X aka this is their slot so he
knows that they're way more metahumans
out there that could be helping but
prediction number three I think there's
a chance that Batman is actually
thinking of someone specific and that
person is not Superman will actually
explain more about this in a second
because it kind of comes up again let's
get at that trailer a credit
you said you'd come now let's hope
you're not too late okay so you all know
what we're wondering here who was alfred
talking to you know that is speculating
but we've got our own theories Alfred
said he said you'd come let's hope
you're not too late first up let's just
do the easy guess right now Superman
he's literally in the advertisements for
this movie we know he will be in this
movie and a lot of people think that the
red shading in the corner of the screen
probably the shoulder of this character
is how else hate but something about
this feels like this character is a
little more distant than just Clark so
remember how I was saying that Batman
might have one more metahuman tucked up
his sleeve well just like how civil war
was used as a kind of backdoor debut to
spider-man
we're thinking maybe another hero in the
lineup is going to be debuted in this
movie and maybe this is him or her right
here got some options a lot of people
think that shoulders not red it's brown
like Hal Jordans flight jacket so Green
Lantern I mean we mentioned it earlier
and this might be the perfect way to
introduce the character into the becu
but also maybe Alvarez has been tasked
with hiding a mother box and this is him
staring down Steppenwolf like a badass
that sounds like Alfred but then the
other big guess considering that this
character has a movie coming soon too is
Captain Marvel aka Shazam aka Billy
Batson the red shoulder could be from
the red on his costume and he's
basically a superman level hero so the
Justice League could definitely use them
by the way just so we're on the same
page to Zam who is also known as Captain
Marvel but not the MCU one is actually a
young boy named Billy Batson who can
turn into a full-grown superhero by
saying the word Shazam since he's a kid
it would make sense that Batman would
hesitate to bring him and maybe he's
having some young Jason Todd flashbacks
but then my final guest is actually
going back to our first guest sure maybe
this is Superman but something tells me
that if it is it's not going to go well
I mean about this moment feels a little
like who shot mr. burns to me I feel
like this person is actually there to
hurt Alfred not help them can you just
imagine that Alfred thinks he's there to
help and then after a moment he realizes
oh this person is not on my side
so brainwash Superman or not
feels like this could be the last we see
of Alfred in the DCE you don't ask me
why it just feels like that
but most importantly who do you all
think is standing in front of Alfred let
us know in the comments down below and
be sure to check out all of our other TV
show and movie breakdowns there are so
many coming out right now and if you're
a fan of DC Marvel Game of Thrones Star
Wars really any nerdy things we've got
more videos you're going to enjoy so
subscribe to us four way way more also
holler all your theories about this
movie to me on twitter i'm at fimo I'm
at Sam batcher and thank you guys so
much for welcoming me we'll see you next
time